okay so I don't normally do new stories
but this one is so cool to me this is
something that is so awesome for me as a
fan of these games the first time I beat
Metal Gear Solid 4 ps1 I literally went
back the very next day and beat it a
second time all in one day I've loved
those games they're so emotionally
resonant they're my favorite games of
all time I even review them if you
haven't seen my review of it I did a
long time ago from time to time I will
review video games and I try to do it
every once in a while just for something
that's important to me or special to me
I'm not as good with doing it with new
games I'd like to change that though
more on that in the future but just last
night - amazing announcements happened
they've announced they're officially
again going forth with a Metal Gear
Solid movie produced by Avi Arad or
however you say his name of spider-man
and various other Marvel films and they
announced a brand new Metal Gear Solid
game the Japanese title translates to
Metal Gear Solid Ground zeroes which
will more than likely be changed for its
American release because that really
does not make any sense these games
meant something to me when I played them
these are emotionally resonant games
they're not just really fun stealth
action games there are great characters
great storylines and a large amount of
emotional depth now I'm extremely
excited for the idea of a Metal Gear
Solid movie because normally video game
adaptations are horrible that's because
they try to adapt like a Super Mario
Brothers or a Silent Hill you know games
that are a lot of fun to play but
there's nothing really a most do you
really think I mean Super Mario Brothers
is a great game but there's no there's
no emotional depth in the game but from
a movie perspective what are you gonna
do you're gonna have Bob Hoskins and
John Leguizamo jumping around with
Dennis Hopper as Bowser I mean seriously
what but the Metal Gear Solid games have
such good characters and an excellent
storyline that you can really get some
serious drama out of a movie adaptation
if you do it right I'm excited about the
prospect of a Metal Gear Solid movie I
think that is such a cool idea but at
the same time I'm very worried the last
time something this close to my heart
was adapted into a live action film
we got Dragonball Evolution and you all
know how I feel about that I hate that
movie it is my number one most hated
movie ever
I can't stand it that's why I'm scared
of the idea of a cowboy bebop
live-action film which by the way would
actually be my dream to direct that
would be incredible anyway
I'm scared what could happen to my
precious metal gear please please
respect it after the new game coming out
that's the kind of game that would
actually make me buy the system I don't
even have to play another game I would
buy a Playstation 4 if that's the system
that it's released on just to play that
game that's how much I love those games
I'd like to talk a little bit more about
video games in the future on my channel
so I have an idea of what I'm gonna do
when Resident Evil retribution comes out
later this month I'm gonna review one of
my favorite Resident Evil games because
I love those games I can relate it to
movies but I can also have fun talking
about video games and maybe in the
future I'll have like all the new
systems and I'll actually be good at
getting the games and playing them it's
just they're so expensive you know and
then you have to beat them it's harder
to do than just a movie review but I do
enjoy video games a lot of people have
asked me that now if you guys have not
seen my review for the original for
Metal Gear Solid games it is on my
channel right now but I thought I'd
leave you with a skit that I did for
that review if you've played the Metal
Gear games than you know about the codec
wear snake is able to talk to people and
you see their face in his face and it's
like it's a lot of fun I did a parody of
that so I'd like to leave that with you
and as always guys thanks a lot for
watching let me know what you think of
the Metal Gear adaptation if you're into
the games how you feel about the idea of
something so sacred and precious to
gamers being adapted into a film let me
know below and as always if you liked
this and you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes dota con snake are
you ok I've been down in every fire and
I can't get this door open
which door I'm on level 2b snake you
need to go back to level 2a and use the
keycard to get in on a god that room is
filled with poison gas you need the
perineum crystals Baratheon crystals
press the select button to view your
items select button what are you talking
about Otacon I'm gonna die here you need
to find the gem of understanding but
akan press r2 to see if you have it
snake did I ever tell you the story of
how my father died it's about 25 minutes
long Annika there are too many of them
hi